après
salut pour mattel com minerva pathe
samat allez-vous ce passage en force
avait des beaux yeux mais tient ce matin
c'est bien mordu 5e vous souvenez on a
eu 10 pions sur les différences à la fin
de la journée rappeler de ça on sait ce
que c'est la discrimination à ses deux
fils de poète respecter est ce que vous
avez envie qu'on fasse une expérience
sur la discrimination oui j'ai près puis
ok alors ce matin on va faire quelque
chose en lien avec ce recul je vais
c'est paris la classe en deux ce matin
on va diviser notre groupe en deux gros
il va y avoir un groupe de petits et un
groupe de grains et là j'ai fait une
recherche et là je me suis aperçu que la
ligne entre les grands et les petits
c'était un maître 34 ce que j'ai lu
aussi qui m'a étonné mais je les lui
c'était vraiment dans des livres
scientifiques
il ya des recherches qui disent que les
petits sont supérieurs
qu'est ce que ça veut dire supérieur ça
veut dire que les petits sont plus
intelligents les petits sont plus
créatifs
les petits sont plus rapides
les petits sont aussi plus sages font
des travaux plus proche alors c'est ce
qu'on dit dans mes élèves sont
supérieures mesure 1 m en 4 et moins ils
font partie du groupe des petits jirga
dream ou n'écoutent pas les preuves
liées comme sow il joue il ya partout
la preuve je pense bien dans rémy
embobiner moi je pense que c'est un gros
gros si je dois vérifier sol en mai à
voilà d'or c'est ce que je pense et rémy
tu vas porter tant dossard aujourd'hui
tu le mets phare de sutton chandail qui
est allé s'asseoir vous venez d'assister
aux premières minutes d'une expérience
hors du commun à saint valérien de
milton fait de saint-hyacinthe il
enseignante de troisième année a décidé
de donner à ses élèves une leçon de
discrimination déjà la veille
annie leblanc préparer le terrain à la
télévision dernièrement il ya eu un gros
gros gros débat ça commençait de
l'émission télévision dimanche soir
ok ça s'appelle tout le monde en parle
et il ya un monsieur qui était là cette
émission là c'est un piia ok puis lui
disait que les gens qui avaient la
couleur de la peau qui était noir ils
disaient qu'ils étaient moins
intelligent qu'est ce que vous pensez de
sabrina au tournoi requins blancs
intelligents
toi tu penses que la couleur a pas de ça
fait pas de différence et ça c'est un
des meilleurs groupes de ma carrière
les enfants sont charmants beaucoup
d'enfants qui veulent travailler qui
veulent apprendre qu'ils sont intéressés
qui sont curieux
mal alain belsoeur qui bat mail quand
chinois là est vraiment intelligente et
si noir en plus que vous savent pas me
répondre mais à l'intérieur de son lot
quand même les préjugés probablement que
sa culture par les télévisions
ce qu'ils entendent ce qu'ils disent ben
moi c'est un délit qui est lié noirs
sont pose son hip hop au pôle fret ont
circulé m'arrivait il
il volait des choses du moyen le plus
tendance à voler des choses plus tarder
à être plus méchant une plus pour lui ce
en quoi cela question bien spécifiques
les préjugés raciaux vous intéresse
parce qu'ici dans le fond c'est un
milieu assez homogène la crise dommage
un événement très homogène mais je pense
que la plupart des enfants dont un jour
sortir de saint-valery peut-être
travailler peut-être juste rencontrer
des gens je pense que ça peut les aider
aussi dans ce sens là à être plus
ouverts aux autres à être plus tolérants
former de futurs citoyens
c'est un début dany leblanc son autre
objectif est plus urgent sortir la
discrimination quelle qu'elle soit de sa
propre classe parfois ceux des raisons
physiques
ça peut être la pauvreté ça peut être
l'élève mettons un enfant qui est
efféminé ou en a mais c'est rare qui est
pas un enfant dans un groupe qui est
pris comme bouc émissaire
on a beau essayer de faire des choses
mais juste le fait d'en parler les
préjugés et reste là malgré toutes les
interventions qui ont été faites en
maternelle en première en 2e et en 3e
moi je le sais j'ai investi je fais des
choses des activités à partir de livres
à partir d'actifs des événements concret
puis chars en pick up on a l'impression
que sa soeur de l'autre côté annie
leblanc a donc décidé de prendre les
grands moyens
est ce que je vais faire c'est vraiment
faire vivre la différence la
discrimination à partir de
deux gros je vai séparer mon groupe en
deux
les petits et les grands et je vais
traiter les deux groupes d'une façon
différente expérience inusitée qu'elle
s'apprête à réaliser s'appuie sur des
bases scientifiques solides depuis plus
de 50 ans des chercheurs étudient la
psychologie des groupes entre eux un des
pionniers de ce champ de recherche le
professeur henri tâche vail est un
survivant des camps nazis qui a voulu
comprendre d'où viennent les préjugés et
la discrimination dans les années 60 en
grande bretagne il a réalisé ses
premières expériences de séparation de
groupe
richard bourhis est un ancien étudiant
d'henri tâche vesle il est maintenant
professeur à l'uqam en étage fel dans
ces études l'original a réussi à
démontrer que la catégorisation eux nous
tout simplement
et aussi l'identification à son propre
logo est suffisante pour créer un effet
de discrimination en faveur de notre
propre groupe et compte l'autre gros
comment at on trouvé que l'être humain
discriminer naturellement tout
simplement en séparant un groupe donné
en deux selon des critères souvent
absurdes automatiquement et à tout coup
les membres des deux groupes se mettent
à favoriser leur propre groupe au
détriment de l'autre
qu'est ce que ça dit sur la nature
humaine bien j'ai des gens qui disent
que c'est depuis les primes à queue on a
ce comportement là qui est un peu un
comportement de tribus ou de cela tout
simplement parce que dans la nuit des
temps les humains avaient à se défendre
entre eux les travaux dans ritaj bell
ont inspiré toute une génération de
chercheurs en psychologie sociale et
même des enseignants du primaire
l'exercice de cette institutrice
américaine est à l'origine d'un
mémorable documentaire en 1970 john
elliott a constaté que ces jeunes élèves
développer des préjugés raciaux
il vivait pourtant en iowa dans un
milieu très rurale et très blanc pour
leur faire vivre le racisme de
l'intérieur et la frapper un grand coup
en favorisant systématiquement un des
deux groupes
jen elliott a instauré un climat de
ségrégation instantané
l'exercice n'a duré que deux jours mais
il a révélé des aspects troublants de la
nature humaine
quatorze ans plus tard des interviews
réalisées avec les mêmes enfants devenus
jeunes adultes ont révélé qu'ils avaient
été profondément influencé par cette
expérience
et le documentaire a été projeté à
gauche générations d'élèves et
d'étudiants partout dans le monde
lorsque annie leblanc a vu le
documentaire elle a décidé d'aller de
l'avant avec sa propre expérience avec
l'accord de tous les parents de la
commission scolaire et de la directrice
de l'école
diane racines elle se servira de la
taille des enfants pour les séparer
c'est un caractère qui qui elle touche à
bhl les enfants pas de pouvoir sur ça
c'est arbitraire comme caractère donc ça
se rapproche beaucoup de ces cars dont
parle de discrimination la couleur de la
peau un peu pochon injuste et qu'est ce
que vous pensez que l'expérience
pourrait faire quand ils vont l'avoir
senti qu'un point d'avoir vécu j'ai
l'impression que ça va être plus facile
après que ceux-ci sérieusement leur
valeur que saverne à leur façon de
penser
les élèves qui sont fermés les grains
doivent porter le dossard je me suis dit
que la journée vous allez le porter
toute la journée dans la classe à la
récréation par dessus mon manteau ça me
scie à la caf et la brioche
ohlala voit que je vois mes dents très
indisciplinés qui font du bruit
alassane surprend pas c'est un fait ils
sont plus dérangeant aussi les gains ou
dakar à la qui va y avoir de
particuliers aujourd'hui comme mes
petits sont supérieurs mais petits vont
avoir des privilèges particuliers
je vais m'en fais tout ce qu'ils vont
avoir le droit de faire vos jours
au départ ils étaient très contents ne
vit beaucoup de ges des sourds et je
voyais les yeux pétillants des way des
gestes comme ceux ça a été très rapide
tout de suite en les annonçant les
privilèges
il y en a qui étaient très heureux puis
voulait pas passer à côté je pense
cinq minutes avant la récréation les
petits vont pouvoir aller se préparer et
être prêt à sortir avant tout le monde
aussi pour le loge
ce midi les petits qui vont pouvoir
quitter cinq minutes plus tôt en plus ce
matin seulement les petits vont pouvoir
utiliser les défis est allé glisser sur
la butte
oui david dépôt le truc c'est cette
fougue et éthique sans port camargue
katif le sont pas vraiment à katyn mais
que son pote travailler dans les petits
ont fait d'acheter ce que tu en penses
que ça veut pas dire que migrants mais
pointe et bien ces délits se trouvait
moi j'écris
c'était une finale et lycées des
recherches scientifiques qui me l'ont
prouvé dans son sang tiers des gens en
début de journée l'atmosphère était
changé contrairement à ce que je pensais
moi je pensais que ça allait être très
long avant d'établir s'occupe de tout
sans trop bien puis ça a été très très
rapide deux fous complètement
si la journée est ce qu ils parlent et
se mettent à côté d'un ami mais pour un
grain un petit est en retard par exemple
où toi tu vas pouvoir choisir goûter un
petit pour aller choisir ton ami ton
compagnon travail en nous un petit
demain m
mais non non bartleby voilà dernier
dernier dernier commentaire c'est normal
que je me sente rejeté deux autres c'est
possible mais c'est une grave dans ces
bien possible que c'est ok alors
recommencer on va faire du français on
va commencer la g 1 alors vert valait
parfait avec jeu qu'est ce que c'est ma
finale avec je vais jamais amusé à
hiesse premier bravo en fait si
évidemment si vous faites la
discrimination
oui c'est vrai mais sur des faits
mais sur des faits je me bats ce que
j'ai lu i et on agit comme ça
aujourd'hui
oui tenue super tournoi mois pour que
tout soit d'accord oui oh ben ça veut
dire que tu es bien chanceuse est une
petit degré de considérer chanceux et 10
passes et une expertise du gros de ce
sont les médias qui vient blé déjà me
voilà alors savamment gens sont forts
dans ces moments fait remarquer par des
ford allait devoir les trouver à la
chanson à un ami je vais envoyer cet été
iker faut aller vers la première femme
comme elle
au pluriel sa part pourquoi par exemple
on y touche son écriture c'est moins 326
atteint 23,4
ok tu as bien raison je suis d'accord
avec toi michael était passé c'est tout
non c'est quoi la prochaine étape peut
demander l'aide d'un ami si tu as besoin
ça se peut il ya certains élèves que qui
était beaucoup moins performant dont je
pense à michael entre autres de la
première idée qui me viennent qu'un
enfant qui performent qui est capable
j'espère leur les épaules la façon de
soutenir les yeux la tristesse là c'est
vraiment le c'était plus il dit canet
on apprendra qu à voir avec un manège et
où la rébellion est resté tout petit ça
s'est pas vendu jusqu'à l'élection
j'aurais aimé j'aurais aimé ça qui elle
qui prouve pays qui avance qui
continuent leur démarche mais c'est pas
arrivé
tu veux pas rentrer prévu les joueurs
aiment c'est parce que moi parce que tes
amis sont dans les pc pour quelles
raisons
qu'est ce qui fait que seul goût d'être
dans l'ombre ou qui continue toujours
invaincus t'en as pas besoin de ces
privilèges l'autre cinq locaux besoin de
tes correct comme ça donc pas besoin de
sortir le bon bout
la db
ça il ya des gars qui sont atteints
d'hépatite tout comme yann at il va même
très gros c'est seulement sa blanche
qu'est ce que c'est très intense
habituellement quand les enfants
prennent leurs seins c'est une ligne
vous avez le premier arrivé premier se
placer et suite hélas aujourd'hui j'ai
rien mentionné j'ai peur je ne
mentionner aucune consigne par rapport à
ça quand je suis allé me placer en avant
il ya eu deux groupes se sont installés
les petits d'un côté les grains de
l'autre côté
5 j'ai besoin de mentionner l'on sentait
déjà que l'aixois stupeur pierre-luc
c'est un enfant qui a été victime de
discrimination
c'est un enfant qui se sent agressé
facilement alors des fois il peut faire
une colère terrible pour un événement
qui est très très mineures alors
qu'aujourd'hui je les vraiment poussé à
bout avec tous ces commentaires là mais
j'avais l'impression qu'ils vivaient
bien j'ai l'impression qu'il sentait que
le point était pas juste sur ses épaules
que c'était partagé avec les autres
élèves de la classe b 7e place
le court je campais de riches sont hors
de ma chaise
2 plus trop trousset 25 c'est très bien
donc laurence c'est une petite a très
bien réussi son problème de
mathématiques elle a régné retenu une
bonne et moi mais pepsi avant de quitter
pour le dîner rappel de la consigne vous
avez le droit les petits d'inviter un
ami mais un ami ne peut pas s'inviter à
votre table si les grains
à
m
ok alors vous rangez vos lits on va
commencer l'après midi jemil c'est quoi
exactement but des français
j'avais pas votre journée allez petit
est ce que vous aimez votre journée les
grains ce que vous aimez pas de joie oui
bonjour nous si je voudrais c'est
peut-être pas dire que je veux pas être
intelligents connaissent pas soit
grandie à un moment donné puis il s'est
fait rentrer sinon comme je joue alors
pendant la période s'en vient je vais
vous donner du travail à la les petits
vont pouvoir faire des cartes de saint
valentin les grands vous votre priorité
c'est du travail personnel il est un
film on aurait dû prendre eau de vie de
maman travaille pour la mission
je vais attendre qu'on avait hier vieux
michael qui est pas un statut chapeau
pointu c'est super ce que c'est un grand
remerciement lire les mots de la bouche
je m'imaginais que ce que j'allais dire
ça allait avoir un effet mais je pensais
pas avoir le soutien des enfants parce
qu'au début de la journée c'était vous
qui l'aviez ça mais à un moment donné au
stade ben oui c'est venu tout seul chez
moi j'étais étonné de la nature humaine
se voyant que ce soit comment ça que
quand ils sont pas plus vif que ça
j'aurais aimé ça dans le fond qui il y
aurait tout moment donné puis deux
années de montée de force paris v alors
pour terminer la journée que mes petits
vous êtes maintenant congés vous avez
fini votre journée partez vous allez
rejoindre diana bon vous avez une
activité spéciale qui vous appuie là où
les petits boulots les graves ou rester
ici avec moi j'ai attendu une tous les
postes qu'ils soient partis pierre façon
votre image
alors je vous demandais d'approché venu
s'asseoir
ce matin quand vous avez commencé la
journée je vous ai demandé ce que vous
voulez vivre une expérience sur la
discrimination ma vie dit oui oui oui
oui
alors aujourd'hui vous avez vécu une
expérience
ok je le sais toute la journée j'ai fait
exprès ok pas parce que je vous aime pas
pour que vous appreniez quelque chose
ok ce que je suis là ça va revenir
ok on va votre four n'en semblent encore
c'était pour la journée ok je sais que
ça a été tu le vois alexandra que les
yeux pleins d'eau vous avez vu que moi
aussi quand pensez-vous ça a été facile
pas facile non plus
qu'est ce que tu en penses
est ce que tu penses que tout ce que
j'ai dit aujourd'hui le y avait une
raison pour laquelle je le dis tiens je
te dis jamais ton lui états unis
non parce que c'était dû à ta grandeur
que tettey - est bonne aujourd'hui
alexandre maman quand toi tu penses que
tu aimes pourquoi tu penses que tu aimes
web en utilisant du courage pour que ce
soit juste
demain ça va être votre savoir et donc
demain matin change la vapeur de côté
c'est vous qui avez les privilèges et
eau qui est ce que ça faisait du bien
vous pouvez enlever votre de ça si ça
vous fait
on les dépasse merci important pour vous
de renverser les rôles oui oui c'est
très important que ce soit équitable
justement l'aspect de justice là puis
pour kid un sentiment ou si c'est pas la
même chose de vivre la discrimination et
d'en donner à gré quelqu'un qui sont
victimes des mines et villes qu est ce
qu on a bien vu
alexandra pense que c'est ce que tu vis
toi est-ce que c'était d'accord avec so
we are qu'en skating traite de grosse
c'est comme la discrimination qui trop
sympathie gallo est ce que tu penses que
maintenant après avoir vécu soffin
suffisent à me de la classe moyenne
capable encore de dire des choses comme
ça tous les amis de la classe ainsi et
c'est comme si tu es aussi l'expérience
c'est apprendre est comme dans ma poule
le faisait beaucoup pour lui
pour lui mais pour tous les enfants de 6
ans victime mais cette année c'est lui
c'est cet enfant lucky qui est victime
de discrimination pour un caractère sur
lequel il pas de pouvoir ce qui est très
très très important c'est que là les
amis dans l'autobus
ils s'attendent de vous voir comme vous
êtes c'est tantôt dans il faut pas
qu'ils le devine d'avancé vous vous avez
plus durement pour moi qu'ils sachent
tout de suite ils vont l'apprendre
demain en sept ans à quoi pour dire
qu'ils vont en faire moins de la
discrimination vous avez des hauts
d'hier - bêtise des commentaires
négatifs
j'espère qu'il y en aura - pourquoi ce
serait comme ça parce qu'ils vont avoir
compris mon avoir vécu oui ils vont
l'avoir vécu vont l'avoir intériorisé
une question quels sont les meilleurs
et vous dix ans les plus achetés duchère
caméraman
bon médecin
c'est du bon matin pour cent
alexandra j'aimerais que mes pores de sa
peau mate allez-vous satin doll et bien
oui ce que vous avez eu une bonne soirée
qui est le patron de la commission
scolaire qui ai téléphoné chez moi hier
soir pour me dire qu'il était vraiment
mais vraiment pas content de ce qui
s'était passé hier il était absolument
en désaccord avec tout ce que j'avais
dit à l'ats moi mon patron c'est un
homme c'est un homme qui est très grand
ok à l'ail été insultés beaucoup
beaucoup beaucoup que je parle des
grains de cette façon là à là il m'a
fait sentir que moi j'étais une petite
et il m'a nommé plein d'arguments pour
dire que dans le fond c'était pour les
petits qui était supérieur mais bien les
grains si tu parles saillie qui dirige
le pays
les grains il m'a nommé plein premier
ministre notre nouveau premier ministre
du canada monsieur à part un grand parti
en grand elle m'a parlé désolé épais que
le you and i do kids south aux aléas et
et qu'on en voit ce qui se dit ici
non mais qui on avoir pensé ni dégâts
les grains dans ce matin on n'a pas le
choix ne s'est mis alors on sait que
seuls allegra qui sont super ya dix ans
nichant dans pierre lefranc de compris
soit donnée quant à sarah un fait
cher on recommence une autre journée
parce qu'on a quand même une journée de
classe on a des choses à apprendre
beaucoup aujourd'hui vers 9 heures on va
s'y prendre une petite pause pour
maigrir parce que vos muscles de dakhla
vont avoir besoin de bouger
c'est très bien est-ce que vous avez
remarqué que sarah n'a pas eu besoin des
deux pour se rappeler des états parfait
à la benjamine fois que le suivant si un
coup droit très bon niveau
campa distincts petit est ce qu'il ya
quelqu'un qui pourrait l'aider
lapierre lui sa came as far hills au
plus bas et c'est au pluriel dans pierre
luc merci tu l'a aidé à trouver ce en
prenant pierre lux et un coin
salomi les photos l'inversion des rôles
ça s'est installée assez rapidement
contrairement à ce que je pense et je
pensais qu'ils allaient avoir encore
beaucoup plus d'élèves qui allait se
révéler qu'elle essayait de défendre
l'égalité tout ça ça paul yeux tellement
ce matin ils y ont décidé d'embarquer
dans le jeu puis de le faire c'est quand
des tout petits épisodes déjà pilleurs
amérique et est-ce qu'on vienne voir
voix d'or bienvenus ok alors ce que je
vais faire sortir
résidant avec un vincent poux
alors ce départ par exemple pour les
poignets
paris en tête du monde
parce que la porsche poursuit veut que
j'arrête de maigrir parce que ça démarre
tout ou pas tout acte fort je dis tout
le temps même tous où je trouve que
c'est trop souvent à son goût
j'ai hâte à ce que tu dis là pour tout
le monde vous devez dessiner votre
personne avec ce que vous serez
aujourd'hui comment vous vous sentez
voyez tous vos studios sur votre cupide
je ne veux plus rien voir sur les
pupilles tard c'est fait vous venez vous
asseoir en avant ici avec moi
on estime en effet que vous aurez choisi
comment vous avez vécu votre journée
aujourd'hui qui nous a pas encourager on
n'aurait pas été capable de faire le
concours démarre bien puis parce qu'être
encouragée des anti blanc fait plus vite
hier je vous avais un courage et puis
aujourd'hui je vous ai pas encourager
mais moi j'y dis que si la confiance en
soi est ce que tu penses que tu tiens
qu'est ce qui a changé c'est pas la
différence à ce jour du pillage occupe
aujourd'hui une totale la nappe happée
cap ailleurs généralisée
ok je t'ai pas qui fâchent moi je
maladroite
ok ça te fait de la peine je vois juste
le fait de dire à chaque bête est encore
triste rx au hockey hier j'avais
l'impression à la fin de la journée que
le message avait passé et que c'était
clair pour les enfants à la fin du jour
d'hui de la journée d'aujourd'hui le
site et j'avais pas l'impression que
c'est clair il y avait beaucoup
d'agressivité encore beaucoup de
dénonciation emprise enfin c'était pas
en fait ils ont pas dit ce que je
voulais un temps parce que avec tout ce
qu' ils y ont vécu avec tout ce qu'ils
ont subis et ou sur ça pour donner le
résultat que je pense et efforts
commencent de ben ali
oui bon de même attendus la cour et les
blancs est ce que ça vous tente
elle est où le pire moment de
l'expérience à la fin car les enfants
ont voulu faire avant jantes kim 0,8
mais c'est toi ni de certains moments de
découragement 10 ans non y auriez
compris ça tout l'exercice porté
là-dessus d'arrêter faire la
discrimination pilot il revenait avec
son accord le désir de le faire
d'instinct c'est l'instinct qui revenue
c'est ça ça a été difficile à accepter
la guerre sans face à t il convient
comme à 20 a perdu 3
trois semaines plus tard nous sommes
retournés dans la classe dany leblanc le
lendemain il était plus qu'un plus
serein par rapport à ça je pense qu'il y
avait eu teint de laisser tomber la
poussière un peu puis de d'avoir remis
les choses en place et de sécuriser il
savait que j'étais redevenu les vrais
annie puis l'eau et il ya eu beaucoup
plus de commentaires intéressants lequel
est dans l'esprit de l'expérience
pourquoi en fait partie à quoi ça sert
très différent si les autres sur 6 4 14
de bon nombre de défauts puis aussi le
défaut de votre carte était aussi
d'écouter ça
quelle était la firme important
kg tout à blanc
est-ce que tu étais aussi bon que
d'habitude je te les plus pourris
comment pourquoi je pense justement
concentré parce que je savais que tout
le monde a l'air et de moi tue pas c'est
contre nature ce que j'ai fait c'est
sympa de bon ça c'était absolument
l'inversé de ce que je fais seulement
avec les enfants puis ça a été très
bouleversant de voir les enfants comme
ce petit pour pouvoir agir autrement
this pour que l'expérience fonctionne
fallait que j'ai juste comme ça on
remarquait que l'expérience a semblé
très difficile pour plusieurs de tes
amis mais toi ça semblait pas atteindre
de la même façon pourquoi ma phase que
sa fille de 2 ans petit que j'avais un
ami puis une culture de cap comme ça
puis elle nous a demandé rassembler en
expérience alors il ya l'expérience à me
donner une idée qu'elle s'était pour la
france c'était quoi la discrimination
avant mais que veulent les personnes les
ont arrêtés depuis que le vécu
l'expérience
ah bon qu'est-ce que vous avez arrêté de
faire des 10 criminels les personnes qui
étaient comme nous tout comme qui par
exemple comme pierre-luc puisque et bien
lui que les gros mais avant on tourne le
le discriminé mais maintenant aucun cas
quelqu'un qui qu'elle discrimine ben on
est avec lui l'ont on dit que le poids
face aux cycles
je voudrais que les gens retiennent de
tout ça quelques illuminations s'est
replié reiser seulement fait à pleurer
les gens et à l'iran la colère j'ai vécu
ça la rue c'est pas une blague
ça fait vraiment mal dans le cas
qu'est-ce que tu n as toi-même que je
suis que je me fâche mais ça a été chaud
plus gentil
capteur pierre leca vive le matin et
maintenant ils arrivent ils semblent
plus sereins
il ya vraiment eu à ce niveau là un gros
gros changement c'est certain que pierre
lequiller un caractère qui est
particulier et il ya des choses encore à
travailler mais on a enlevé une partie
importante qui nous permet maintenant de
travailler sont avec lui
c'est pas une expérience confie l'un
porte quelle façon je ne le ferai pas
dans n'importe quel contexte
je le ferai pas non plus dans un bus
éloignés c'est je suis contente
les enfants ont associé beaucoup plus à
leur vécu par rapport à la
discrimination qui se faisait dans ma
classe que par rapport peut-être au noir
où ça vaut la peine d'être vécue quand
on a un problème à régler ça
sinon c'est trop c'est trop difficile
pour l'impact que ça peut avoir tout de
suite le quotidien pour les enfants
il a mis des fois il y avait des preuves
rage que j'ai même pas parce que je
pensais
toi tu as été victime de discrimination
pourquoi est il traita de grosses icônes
à nikos et est ce qu'il le fera encore
non et depuis quand ils ne le font plus
depuis l'expérience je savais pas ça
est ce que tu as appris quelque chose
toi sale cette expérience j'ai appris
que maintenant je peux laisser passez la
discrimination quand je vais en avoir
sur elle de dire de l'arrêter est ce que
tu penses que tu vas vraiment retenir de
tout cela jusqu'à 50 mètres en adulte
die qu'est ce que c'est qu'est ce que je
vais retenir musical
je sentis qu'est-ce que quelques jardins
des mots comme l'était croûte contenu
tout le jus ressenti que c'est quoi
quelqu'un qu'on soit des surplus ça va
me dire faut que j'arrête le jeu parce
qu'il ya beaucoup de choses qui vont
rester
est ce que ça veut dire que tous les
jours ça va bien aller
je postule pas ce que ça veut dire qu'il
y aura plus de situations ils voient
discriminées
sinon plus jupo certaine mais je sais
maintenant que quand je dis le mot
discrimination ou quand je fais
référence à l'expérience
je sens que les enfants sont touchés par
ça et je vois juste dans leur visage
dans leurs yeux qu'ils ont une
différence
oh
ça y est
mais mes copains